hello
i'm alex glaser i'm a data science
contractor from
london uk and my talk is using
algorithm x to re-analyze the last uk
general election
i don't know if anybody here has
actually heard of algorithm x or used it
before
um i will come to what exactly it is a
bit later on
but uh i'm going to start off with
talking
a little bit about why i've ended up
using it as well and for that i'm gonna
have to talk a few
for a few minutes about uh uk politics
as well hopefully it'll just be a quite
a quick overview i won't go into too
much detail
so um basically the main legislative
body
of the uk is the house of commons and
it's got 650
mps or members of parliament and the way
that these 650 mps are chosen
is that the uk is divided into 650 what
are called
constituencies they try and uh
make them as equal population size as
possible
geographically someone could be a bit
bigger or smaller but try and have the
same population in each one
uh and at every general election each
elector
gets one vote so they can uh get to vote
for
uh a party uh or a person who represents
a political party
and at the end of the night they count
and whoever has the most votes
gets to win the seat the seat is another
name for the sort of constituency and
so you get the most votes you end up
representing uh
this constituency in parliament and this
is what's called the
first past the post method as well
and if the party wins more than 325
seats they get to form the government
really if they don't then there's always
coalitions or some sort of
deal is brokered um
now so basically the uk doesn't vote
directly for the prime minister they
tend to vote for a political party and
whoever leads that party
then ends up becoming prime minister as
well
now as with most voting systems there's
some pros and cons to it uh the pro
advantage is that it's very simple to
understand um
if you get them if you get more votes
than anybody else you get to become the
member of um member parliament for that
constituency
and the other thing as well is that's
also quite important for for the people
in the uk
is that there's a link to your mp and
their constituency
so for example if i wanted to uh let my
opinion be known
i can write directly to my member of
parliament now i may not always agree
with her as a female mp um but i've been
pleased to let my opinion be known and
that's a person who i write to
directly if i want my opinion to be
heard um
now with regard to the disadvantages of
it one that may be that the majority may
disapprove of the winner
so there's often a case sometimes you
can have somebody who has a sizeable
minority
they've said the opposition is split
then they still get in
and quite often you end up with um
and often there are times as well where
you can find
uh people who win but with very small uh
majorities
you could have you could have just two
more votes than somebody else
and you become the member of par member
of parliament there's always a
um people always say what's the most
marginal see and there have been like
quite a few seats in many over the years
where people have only won by a handful
of votes
really and the other thing as well
whilst
from a constituency point of view this
may seem quite fair you get the most
votes
overall the votes over the whole country
are not really proportional
i'm going to sort of show explain uh why
this happened
i'll explain this in a table here from
the last election
so conservatives and labor are the two
major parties in the uk
and in the general election in december
last year we can see that the
percentage here of votes that they both
parties got and the potential seats that
they won
so for example labour got 32.6
of the votes and they got about 31 to
the seats which sounds
quite uh fair whereas conservatives got
43.6 percent of the votes you ended up
with like 56 percent
of the seats which give them this gives
a majority of eight in the house of
commons which is
quite a large majority to have uh this
isn't like the most uh extreme example
of uh sort of a disproportionate result
overall for the country
probably one of the most notorious was
in 2005
where um again conservatives you can see
he got 32.4 percent
very similar to the result that labour
got last year
and they ended up with 196 seats so
again still quite proportional
whereas conservatives with only a couple
of percentage more
35.2 ended up with 355 seats
55 so and it's
big as i said it's because there's a uh
this has first possible say the
disportion effect
now because of this off
after the every general election there's
always calls for why doesn't the uk use
a more proportional
uh voting system and in fact most of the
political parties apart from these two
do uh are in favor of this as well and
after the last general election
there was an article appeared online
which they said that if the uk
had a pr system these would be the
results now this was the day after so
there is the percentages you see here
are slightly different on the previous
page because the results were still
coming in
and they basically said that if they had
if
uh the house comments would look like
this if
based on the results all they did was
they took the
percentage of results overall as a whole
country
and they multiplied that percentage by
um
650 which number seats in the house of
commons
and i remember reading this and
thinking to myself this is a bit too
simplistic a model um whilst pr systems
do try and make a more proportional
uh not try to make the amount of votes
more number of seats in parliament more
proportional to the amount of votes that
were given
it doesn't do it exactly as well and i
couldn't find another country that has a
system
as simplistic as this one and the other
thing as well is that
as i mentioned earlier there is no link
there between the mp and the
constituency which in the uk is
considered to be
quite an important factor so i thought
to myself
is there a way that and also being quite
pedantic as well i thought
i could see if there's something a bit
more complicated than this
and i thought is there a way that uh i
could use the results from the last uk
general election
uh use of a user pl method to try and
see what those results would have looked
like as well
now uh for those people who live in
um let me give you a second
now proportion representation or pr
methods um
they allocate multiple mps to each
political region
so as i mentioned the uk we have uh one
mp gets allocated allocate to
constituency
whereas pr allocates multiple mps so for
example in holland
uh the political region is the entire
country's and
the entire country and the mps get
allocated there in sweden
it's a geographical region and in
ireland
it's they do have a constituency but the
constituencies
have between three to five mps uh who
get uh represent them in parliament
so um i thought i need to a few get a
few uh
ideas and so a few rules and one of the
things was i want to keep the number of
mps the same
it could have been quite simple
initially just have gone oh
in each constituency we can just treble
or quadruple the number of mps and apply
pr technique
um didn't want to do that um and then
the other one is i only want to use
results from the 2019 general election
i.e no inference or prediction
now quite a few pr techniques such as
here the single transferable vote allow
you to have multiple votes so in single
transferable vote you're about to rank
the people you want to vote for like you
can put one two three four
five there or you have other methods of
behaving like germany and new zealand
where
you get a constituency vote and a
regional vote as well
um again i didn't want to do that
because that would have ended up
meaning doing a lot of prediction
building another model
and that could have ended up being a lot
more extra effort
really so i basically tried to follow
the iris technique of having multiple
mps for a constituency but uh what i
would do is i would aggregate
the votes with my merged constituencies
now that left the problem how would you
how would you
uh merge neighboring constituencies as
well
so to give you um an idea of what
the constituency map looks like i've got
here the constituency map
of london uh the uk is divided up into
12 what are called statistical regions
as well
uh i thought i'd keep just use um
just look at the look on a region by
region basis because
i had a feeling that if i tried to use
the uk as a whole with 650
constituencies uh the combinatorics
aspect of that
would be huge so uh again this is a map
of london
after 2019 so uh the
constituencies in red uh uh were won by
the labour party the ones in blue were
won by the conservatives the one in gold
were
won by uh sort of one of those other
other parties the liberal democrats
as well so i tried to find ways how
could you actually merge
neighboring constituencies together and
i sort of
tried a number of techniques um it was
during knockdown i went through the
rabbit hole of
um pentomino tiling um which is
that's a sort of big area it was yeah
it interests me for a little while but
then i really found out
that it didn't quite work in this aspect
and then
i was speaking to a friend of mine who
suggested that if you are going to merge
constituencies together
then they would actually only appear
once so if we merge
two constituencies together you wouldn't
merge one of those with another one
as well and he said it sounded like an
exact cover problem
now uh an algorithm x is something that
you use to solve exact cover problems
so when you've got something where you
want
uh something to appear once and only
once so we've got an example here uh
we've got a universe
you which are the numbers one to seven
and we've got a collection of sets a to
f
here and a to f represents uh sort of a
random set of numbers so here
a is one four seven b is one four now is
it possible
to pick a subset of all these sets so
the numbers one to seven are selected
once and only once so for example if i
selected set a
i would not be able to include b c
um e or f in that because they contain
one of those numbers as well
now the solution here is b d or f
and we actually solve these using
algorithm x as well
another way of looking at the previous
problem was was to maybe
write it as a binary constraint matrix
as well so you can have what you have
ones and zeros in there
ones where represent the columns that
are allocated
uh that are sort of part of that set um
as well and you can perhaps think of
this uh another way to look at this
problem say
can we select a set of rows so that the
sum of each column is equal to one
as well um and if you can actually
represent
your problem as a binary constraint
matrix or something similar to that
then you can actually use a algorithm x
an exact cover
probably one of the most famous examples
is a sudoku puzzle
as well where the numbers one to nine
can only appear once and only once in
each row in each column and in each
three by three grid and the way you
the constraint matrix here is actually
far too big to fit on any sort of slide
um the way you'd build it is you would
say that
the numbers one to nine you'd have a
uh each row would represent each
possible cell
and the fact that the numbers one
tonight could appear in each cell
so you'd actually have 81 times nine
rows
um because like you'd say for the first
cell you'd have numbers one to nine and
then
second cell numbers one to nine um
so you'd have one of those for each uh
that would be number of rows
there are four constraints here as i
mentioned number can only appear once in
each row
so you can each once in each cell once
and only
i'll start that again uh you can only
have one number in each cell
the numbers one to nine can appear once
and only once in each row
they can appear once and only once in
each uh column
and once and only once in each three by
three sort of mini grid
in there so you can create a constraint
matrix
ones and zeros that say that if it
appears here this it should not appear
in these other areas as well
um now i'm not gonna display give you an
example here but if you go to my github
uh code at the end when i show you some
of the work i've done here
i do have an example with sudoku puzzles
as well
and i go into more detail about the the
grid as well
um so but it is actually quite fast
when you uh run it now there's lots of
other problems you can solve using this
i think end queens is probably one
of the other more famous ones as well uh
and there's like quite a few little
websites that show you um explanations
how to do um about when you can use
exact cover
the thing about the problem is actually
it's mp complete there
is no um there's no sort of fancy
mathematics behind it
there's no sort of a quick way of doing
this um
however rather than actually using brute
force
it actually uses doubly linked lists and
there's a thing called the dancing links
method
as well and with that it officially
removes and inserts values
in that and this is what gives its
lightning speed as well
so you end up with a speedy backtracking
algorithm um
the actual algorithm x is basically it's
recursive
depth first a backtracking algorithm as
well
and it does do and it does run
incredibly fast as well
so much faster than since using standard
um brute force
i'll give you i'll tell you how fast it
goes uh oh so
once i knew that this was how it worked
i then decided to
um say okay i've got a potential
solution here
given that uh we've got emerging
constituents together i know they're
going to appear once and only once
can i then use um algorithm x
to merge them together and uh the first
thing i did was i used uh the disjoint
uh command in geopandas as well to see
if constituencies were neighbors so i
had shapefiles for all 650
constituencies
in the uk and i created data frames such
as this one
um so you can say set one is this place
that place and the other and set two is
this place that place and somewhere so
these say for example they would form
a three-way constituency link as well
um now i limited myself to only merging
two
three or four constituencies together uh
the reason for this
is that um whilst in the uk uh
at the moment you only get one mp per
constituency
in the past you were actually allowed to
have multiple members
you were about to have multiple mps per
constituency um it was only in 1948 that
actually became law that you'd only have
one mp per constituency
beforehand you could have had multiple
mps
uh the most were actually for the most
mps they've had represented a single
constituency was four
where uh the city of london where pi
data in london uh used to hold their
meetups
uh when we were allowed to uh they used
to send four mps to parliament
for much of the 18th and 19th century as
well um
and in fact um up until i said like the
first half of the 20th century
there were lots of places which sent two
three or four mps for their
constituencies
so i limited myself to just two three or
four in this case
now just to give you a rough idea of
uh the sort of numbers we were dealing
with here this is uh for london
there are 73 constituencies now if i
wanted to merge
two neighboring constituencies together
i would have to
um uh obviously remove three of them and
i'd have to have an even number there
the way i did this i removed like a
three-way neighbor
uh i removed one at random and then i
was left with 70 constituencies
and i ran algorithmic say how many ways
were there of combining two nebulae
constituencies
and the fact it gave me roughly 540
million solutions and that takes roughly
three and a half hours so um yeah
that's quite a few it's basically doing
over two million solutions a minute
really now i will i didn't actually need
all 540 million of those
and i didn't really want to take three
and a half hours because i was then home
to re-run this
for multiple regions and for multiple
number of seats being merged together
as well now there are a couple of ways
to speed things up
um the one thing about algorithm x it's
actually non-deterministic
so if i um were to put in another data
frame but
the same data frame but in a different
order it would still give me the 540
million solutions but it would give me
give them to me in a different order so
one of the ways to actually speed things
up was just to sort of run it
run it for a few minutes get a couple
million solutions take a random sample
of those solutions
and then exit and then shuffle the data
frame put it back in again a couple of
more million solutions
take a random sample that sped things up
as well
um and the other way i found was to use
a pipe i
kernel um the algorithm x code which was
written by
a competitive python programmer from
iceland
um and you can just do a standard pip
install of this one
um it was written in pure python it just
a new sort of lists
and i found that if you use a pi pi
kernel you've got a speed
increase of up to fivefold really i know
there are other ways
of uh getting faster um of uh making
pythagorean fast things like number uh
in jit
and boost uh this was the easiest way to
make it work
um i just ran i just got it running in a
docker container
and the same code ran as well and i
yeah so i given that i now have
a quick way of aggregate of sort of
merging
uk constituencies constituencies
together
i ran it that's it i ran this for all
the regions of the uk
and i was merging two three or four uh
constituencies together
uh i was used on job lib as well because
it was easily paralyzable
so the whole process took about 15 hours
to run
and i ended up with several hundred
thousand ways of
merging um uk constituencies together
now now i've got that i can then
aggregate the results we had from the
2019 general election
so now that was all done i now had to
find what was a pr technique i was going
to use for that
now if you're only allowed one vote you
kind of pr techniques
uh methods can be divided into sort of
two groupings
there's highest average or divisor
methods or remainder methods
as well so for the highest average
methods so
after each round uh the highest vote
count gets allocated a seat
and then you divide the heist vote count
by some number
um and then again you repeat the process
so whoever's got the highest vote count
after you divide the highest vote um
after
after each round and you repeat this to
all seats allocated
and then the second method is uh
remainder methods where you divide votes
by a quota
uh and then you allocate this integer
value to seats and then a remaining
seats allocated the highest fractional
remainder
i'll run through a few examples now
because i think it might be a bit easier
to understand
so let's imagine we have a scenario
where we have an election of 200 000
votes and we have four seats to allocate
and we have party a has 70 000 votes
party b 50 000 party c
d 46 and 34 000 respectively
the divisor here is the de haunt method
uh this is used in a number of countries
and it used to be used in the uk when
they took part in
eu elections and we can see here after
round one we just take all this um so
the divisor method is we divide the
number of votes after each round
by the number of seats plus one so
in round one none of the parties have
any um have any seats
so we keep um we just do a full rank and
just say um
full count and say who has the most
votes we can see a party a has the most
votes with 70 000
so we allocate them one seat um so now
for round two
all uh parties bcd's votes vote count
remains the same
but party a gets their get their votes
divided by
seats plus one which is two so we end up
now with 35
000 votes and now party b here has got
the most votes because they've got 50
000 uh vote count as well um
and again so the next round we divide 50
uh we divide parties b's
uh vote count by two and we appease
until all four seats have been um
have been uh allocated so we see a party
c wins
of uh seating round three and now in
round four
uh party a has the highest vote count as
well so here
two c to get allocate to party a one
gets allocated party b and c
and none to party d in this method um
there's the there are more methods than
the just the single dehunt method
um we've got the webster method which um
is also known as the saint lagu
method and here we divide after each
round
votes by twice the number seats plus one
uh there's also the
imperiale and the huntington methods
which don't quite divide
we don't quite divide the heist vote
count as aggressively as either the
haunt or
webster methods and these are but these
are id these are methods that are used
around the world
so that's a highest average or divisor
method um
with remainder methods we're going to go
with an example here as well
we're going to use something called the
hair quota we've got exactly the same
scenario
uh with 20 000 votes and four seats and
parties a to d
had the same number of votes allocated
to each one and we see here
the headquarter is total number of votes
divided by seats that's 50 000.
so we divide the total votes by each
party by 50 000
and we can see here that we get 1.4 for
party a one for party b
and number lesson one for party c and d
so if you take the integer value of that
we end up with one seat gets allocated
um to party a uh
because they had value of 1.4 and uh one
to party b because again it's
one or higher as well and we're left
with a remainder so we just take the
non-integer part of that we can see two
seats already been allocated and we're
left with two seats
um so we take the two highest remainder
values and allocate a seat in that one
in this case which are c and d so we can
see here that
um uh each party would win
one seat in in this format as well
um there's another quota called the
droop quota as well which
is um where you take uh it's one plus
total number of votes plus one plus
seats
as well which in this case would be 40
000 one which which actually would give
us the same results as well
so i now have multiple ways that i can
merge maybe in constituencies together
in uk
and i do have six different different
voting methods as well
so i now had lots of ways to simulate
the last uk general election using
algorithm x and using a pr method
where there is at least a link to the
constituency and their mp
now i could have showed you lots of
numbers but i what i wanted to do was
find a sort of
metric so that i could actually sort of
compare the results together
and one of the ways of looking at it was
to use the gallagher index which
measures relative dispersionality as
well
so this looks like very much like a root
mean square error
uh calculation it's basically half the
square root of half the sum of the
observed
percentage um of minus expected
percentages the observed percentage
are the percentage of seats
won in a parliament and the expected
percentage is the actual percentage um
they won in parliament now generally
they say that anything over 10
gives us a disappointing result and for
the last uk general election those
results
were 11.6 um so if i have a result less
than 11.6
then i have sort of a more proportional
result
um so um i ran it for six different
methods i merged two three and four
seats together
and i ran it i ran 10 000 different
simulations
of the uk general election and
calculated the gallagher index
and the mean and the standard deviation
for each of these
um scenarios and these are the results
here i'm a bit old-fashioned in like i
like my means followed by the standard
deviations
in brackets as well uh we can see that
the stand evasions are actually quite
small
in comparison to results so that gives
us a bit more confidence
of these results um a couple of things
that i noticed that we've got the
imperiali and the huntington method
particularly in most two seats together
gave us more disproportionate results
than we have at present in the first
past the post method
as well and the other thing to notice is
that
the more seats you merge together the
more proportional results get according
to the gallagher index
as well which probably makes a bit of
sense so some you're we're putting the
more seats you have available
the more you can um spread the results
against different parties as well um
but we can see here that there are two
methods that give
us uh much lower results and we see the
webster method
and the hair quota method as well gives
a
4.3 um gallagher index of 4.3 and 3.2
respect
respectively so they're much lower than
we'd actually get beforehand
just by way of comparison um according
to wikipedia
um the metric for iron is 3.2
and sweden has what uh and they as
mentioned earlier they use a single
transferable vote
and sweden has one of 0.63 they use a
modified webster method um and
and also they have much larger
constituency sizes as well so pretty
might explain why that one's so much
lower but we can see here that the hair
quota method
gave us a value of 3.2 very similar to
the metric
it's very similar to value in ireland so
given that we've got the hair method
does give us
um fairly proportional results i thought
i would actually then
compare these results with the a again
the simple model that i read in the
paper
many months ago with the actual election
results
um and just to remind you they basically
just took the percentage of votes and
multiplied them
um by a number of seats in parliament
and we can see here that the
conservatives uh rather 287 votes
seats would actually won 295 using the
hair method uh the labour party which
won 211
which would run 211 votes seats using
the simple method have 230
uh the liberal democrats and the
scottish national party the next two
biggest parties
um liberal democrats actually suffer
slightly
um from using the hair method they get
eleven fewer votes for the sim
then a kind of a very basic simple model
and the snp
scottish national party end up with a
similar number of
seats as they would have done using the
hair method as a simple method
whereas you can see in actuality um
these results are very different
so to sum up i basically saw
a table in
the paper several months ago and got
quite annoyed and thought
is there a way that i could actually um
produce something
uh which does uh using the data science
method data science techniques and i
think i've done that and it was a little
project that i i ran
uh during lockdown and sort of occupied
my time whilst um
whilst i wasn't allowed out really um
just find the final thing i just want to
take a few uh thanks and real quick
references
um if you can see my slides these links
are available but
um my github code is on there as well
that i used
and there's also a wikipedia article on
algorithm x
and the dancing links method as well
which sort of
sped things up about how you can then
delete
and insert um um
elements of the list uh which really
sped things up
um one of the reasons i sort of got into
this was there's a guy called joel
lindop
in december 2019 gave a talk at londoner
about first pastor post in pr
um and this sort of got me started down
this sort of rabbit hole and started
thinking about these ideas
as well his paper is available there
uh i'm not gonna gonna attempt to
pronounce the next guy's name
um but he's the competitive python pro
python
python programmer from iceland who wrote
algorithm x python code
uh as well uh there's also um
a guy who did the um pi pi kernel in
sort of docker contained with a pi
pi kernel which used to speed things up
lots of people from the community who
have listed me give this talk
and help me out as well in particular i
want to say thanks to asian dale who
gave me
the idea for exact cover and a final
plug as well
i'm involved with a couple of meetups in
london or when we could actually go out
um one that i organize help organize is
the data science workshop
there's lots of great meetups in london
where you give where you can go to talks
as well pi data being one of them
um we're a bit different we actually
sort of work on
uh code on problems so we turn up there
deciding we want to work on either
kaggle competition
or a blog post or a new library as well
so we have many events
on weekends and evenings so again
hopefully
fingers crossed we may be able to start
this again soon and the final one is
project oiler as well if you don't know
project oil it's a website with 600
mathematical problems
again we meet up we pick three of them
to work on at random as well and we meet
up in one at a local pub in central
london
um there again obviously aren't
happening but
we've got um hopefully sometime next
year we'll be able to start those up
again
okay i'd like to thank you for your time
i hope you found it interesting and
a number of things about um algorithm x
and uk politics and that kind of area
um if you have any questions i'd be
happy to answer them but thank you for
your time
cheers
you